hello everybody what you're about to see
is an interview with Andrew Gould who's
a building designer I'm making this
little introduction because the I lost
the first about 10 minutes of the
interview in terms of video we do have
the audio for the entire interview and
so for the first 10 minutes I'll be
putting up images of his work his
building designs his liturgical designs
as well and at about the 10 minute mark
then the the video will come on and
you'll also also keep adding some images
as the conversation continued and so I
had a really great discussion with
Andrew Gould he's uh he's a friend of
mine but he's also someone who I think
shows us how to integrate the past with
the present in terms of our creative
endeavors and so please enjoy the
conversation and thank you
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world hello
everybody I would like to introduce you
to Andrew Gould
I'm pretty excited it's the first time
that I'm doing this live discussion with
someone directly with them sitting there
in front of me and it's great because
andrew is a longtime collaborator of
mine he's someone whose work I admire
very much we've been working together
several years we started some projects
together in the Orthodox our channel and
many liturgical arts projects he is a
building designer he's a liturgical
designer he's designed several churches
and several buildings in Charleston and
all over the US and so I'm really
looking forward to talking with him
about art and about beauty and its place
in the world and he also the type of
work that he's doing and so Andrew just
to start maybe you can tell because
people I don't think meant might not
have heard about you maybe you can tell
them a little bit about what you do and
maybe how you came to where you are in
terms of your work well I'm an
architectural designer and the
liturgical artist I'm one of these
people who's always known what I want to
do I've wanted to be an architect since
I was two years old and I started
getting introduced to the church when I
was a teenager I actually got introduced
to Christianity through playing the pipe
organ which got me into churches and I
really fell in love with the music and
architecture and the surgical art of
churches and well I've gone through a
long path I was an Anglican for a long
time and about 15 years ago I converted
to Eastern Orthodoxy and I specialized
in the design of Eastern Orthodox
churches in the design and manufacture
of the the furnishings
for them and I also have a specialty in
that I live in the downtown Charleston
historic district here in South Carolina
I design a lot of houses and other
buildings within the historic district
that have to have to fit into the sort
of sort of architecture here so you know
I've got a number of different things I
do but you know it's all kind of it's
all kind of medievalist and looking
towards the the beauty and romance of
the past is this kind of the thing that
ties it all together and maybe that's
that'd be my first question is what is
your approach to the past because the
past for some people can seem like a
burden something that is very heavy that
we need to to escape from other people
are very traditionalist and tied to the
past almost in a slavish manner but what
is it what is your vision of how the
past interacts with us today how we can
live make art today thinking about the
past and how we we live in it well
that's a big question I'm a great lover
of the past whenever I can I travel to
old towns or old city is a visit or
building is almost anything old I just
intrinsically love and I'm one of these
people who feels like I'm not quite at
home in the modern world the everybody
talks about how this is this is the age
of the greatest wealth and comfort and
convenience in the history of the world
and you know I suppose I can see that
but it's awfully hard for me to see that
there's anything particularly beautiful
or worthwhile about the modern world
compared to the beauties that I that I
see in the in the art and architecture
of the past so when I when I'm designing
buildings I'm always I'm always thinking
about how it would have been done
supposing somebody in the 19th or 18th
or 14th or 9th century whatever the
project is would have tackled this
design project and built that building
I'm always thinking about how would it
have been done
in those days you know that doesn't mean
I'm making copies of old buildings or
that I'm using
archaic construction techniques um you
know working in the modern age so I have
to design buildings that suit people's
modern needs and are be able to build
out of modern construction materials but
where possible I try to create a sort of
story of romantic fiction you might say
about how the building could have
happened had it been happening in
another age that being some of that
beauty and character that we see in old
buildings into buildings nowadays mm-hmm
one of the things that I've noticed and
that that is surprising that although
although it's obvious that you're basing
your designs on the past you can see
that you're using certain patterns
certain proportions certain materials
that are identified with the past
there's also a kind of buoyancy in what
you're doing there's something there's
something playful about your your
buildings and your designs that makes it
feel like you are not exactly like you
said it you're not copy directly copying
something from the past but you're
almost as if the past is this this like
giant playground that you jump into and
that you connect things together and you
you create these these almost almost
fantastical buildings but that are still
feel comfortable to still feel like a
home that's that's right
yeah and I'm usually playing at least
two historical references off of one
another in my architecture again because
it's too easy to just copy old buildings
and when people do copy old building is
they tend to come off as kind of cold
and contrived so I'm very fortunate that
I have the specialty designing Orthodox
churches particularly Russian Orthodox
churches because there's not a whole lot
of historical precedent for Orthodox
churches in this country so most of the
time when I'm going to be designing a
church I have to come up with a sort of
historical question supposing they've
been Russian Orthodox people in New
Mexico in the 16th century designing
Russian
Orthodox churches alongside the Spanish
missions you know that's a really
far-fetched historical fantasy but from
on an aesthetic standpoint there's a
solution to that question you know it
never happened
but at history turned out differently it
might have happened you know my own
church here in Charleston is the first
Orthodox Church I designed and
Charleston being being an important
historic district has a wonderful
heritage of how buildings are built the
materials that are used the the general
aesthetic character of the buildings and
there's many different kinds of churches
different denominations in the downtown
area so when I said about designing an
Orthodox Church for Charleston I came up
with this sort of story well suppose
that among the various immigrant groups
that were in Charleston there were
Russians and suppose they built a
Russian Orthodox Church here in the in
the mid 19th century that's not so
far-fetched a historic a fantasy you
know that happened in New York it
happened in San Francisco it might have
happened here Russians had come here but
if we look at the way Russians built
churches in the different corners of the
world back when the Russian Empire
pretty much stretched from one end of
the world to the other you know we can
get a pretty good sense of how they
adapted to local climates local building
traditions and in part the architectural
fashions of the time into those places
and built churches it seemed like they
belong there and I can I can by
extension kind of guess what they would
have looked like had they been built
here and beaten III think it's been very
successful because people people look at
the church as I design and feel it and
they say that that looks like it belongs
here it looks like it's always been here
and in many cases they downright don't
believe that it's a new building right
there they're just convinced it's a
restoration of an old building in some
capacity which is pretty funny but it's
interesting because if you that's the
impression that I get is that the first
impression you get from it is that this
is home this belong here there's
something about it that is totally fits
the invite
that it's there but then as you spend a
bit of time in the space and as you
you're looking and you'reyou're
circulating in the space there's
something else that comes out which is
somewhat this fantastical element that
you talk about to me it seems like the
the fantastical aspect of the story that
you're telling about the building that
you're kind of creating this this
fiction about a building it appears not
not just in the story but it ends up
appearing in the building itself they're
quirky details something about it that
makes you almost that makes you dream of
something that that's both possible and
impossible at the same time I'll be
showing some some images as we're
talking for example the the church that
was just built in Greenville for example
maybe it is it is an Orthodox Church but
you can see when you look at the way
it's built you know with the wood siding
and the manner that it it feels like
it's a like a North American building
but it the structure that is so Orthodox
that that joining together feels both
completely fantastical but also totally
in its place and so there is what I'm
getting to is that there is an aspect of
it which is innovative there's an
innovation in the building and in the in
putting it there but there the
innovation comes about in a desire to
make something which fits the place
totally not out of our out of the
artistic this kind of artistic
temperament of wanting to impose their
style or be yeah you know years years
ago I gave a talk on the characteristics
of Orthodox Church architecture I was
trying to look at all the work that our
churches in the world and try to come up
with some idea of what are the
commonalities among them and I observed
a peculiar thing that they all exhibit a
sense of universality that is that they
seem they seems they are they all have a
quality of sort of Imperial Rome like
like they have that they have an
architectural quality to them the seams
intrinsic to human civilization like
that they could exist absolutely
anywhere all right that's one quality
orthodox churches tend to have but they
also have the quality of being locally
specific they tend
be extremely expressive of the the
climate the geography the national
character of the country they're built
in and then on another hand they seem to
always have a tendency to be exotic you
know if we look back at the first famous
made Orthodox Church Hagia Sophia you
know that was built in Imperial Rome and
yet it does not use the Roman orders the
columns in that church don't follow the
ancient orders of Doric Corinthian ionic
which is astonishing because the the
Romans and the Greeks before them had
been using those orders for all
buildings for a thousand years and all
of a sudden Justinian builds the
greatest and most important Civic
building in his entire empire and it's
just completely bizarre looking it would
it would have looked utterly strange to
people in its time instead of having the
classic columns and lintels it's it's
it's all arches and domes instead of
having Corinthian or ionic columns it's
it has columns that sort of they're
called windblown acanthus they have all
of these sort of disorderly curvaceous
shapes in them and most of these
ornamental details are known to have
come from from the architecture of the
Sassanid persian empire which was the
main enemy of the byzantine moment they
actually chose to ornament the most
important civic temple in the style of
their of their Eastern enemy why did
they do this well in in part the the
Roman Empire at this at this time in the
6th century the dawn of the Orthodox
Church was struggling to distance itself
from its pagan heritage from the thumb
that that huge bureaucratic weight of
the Western Roman Empire they were
trying to be something fresh and new
something exotic and you see this you
see this aesthetic interest going
through Orthodox churches through
through their entire history a thousand
years after Hagia Sophia
ivan the terrible' built the famous
Cathedral of said Basil's in Red Square
in Moscow I mean the strangest-looking
building in the world with this with all
those onion domes with the crazy twisty
shapes and wild colors and crazy
patterns and the brickwork I mean you
know we tend to as historians we tend to
look back at historic buildings and say
you know that was the normal way of
building back then it seems strange to
us but it was normal to them you can't
convince me looking at st. Basil's in
Red Square up that to 16th century
Russians that building look norm yeah
that building must have looked as
bizarre to them as it does to us and it
was clearly designed to look that yeah
yeah you know because they wanted they
wanted their churches to look like
they're not of this world they're part
of the Kingdom of Heaven they're they're
part of the the New Jerusalem they're
not they're not like your house in my
house not like the bank down the street
they're not like the the building the
mayor and it was in you know they're
from the kingdom of God they're like the
they're like the ivory palace you know
so so that's that's that's the quality I
strive for all three of those qualities
I should say yeah and if I to make my
buildings look universally recognizable
as the food of human civilization I try
to look make them look like they're
locally meaningful an expression of the
culture and I try to make them look like
they're they're not quite from this
world that they belong to the real most
or in romance yeah and you know as true
as this is for Orthodox churches I think
it can be equally true for any kind of
building movement
I think that there's something about
those three qualities that you bring up
that really speaks about the Orthodox
vision not just a building but of
Christianity itself you know being this
this joining of the divine and the human
but also being at once you know a
Semitic religion which became the
religion of the Roman Empire and then
you know established itself in the East
and so this kind of desire to join
together things that seemed impossible
but I think even more profoundly there's
something also about the capacity to
have something universal like the
structure of an Orthodox Church you know
the dome and the square or
or the Basilica that we that we use has
this very ordered structure but then you
can see all the variations of these
buildings where you know sometimes even
that pattern almost disappears within
the church and you almost have to know
that it's there but if you looked at it
right away you wouldn't get the sense of
that
so this joining of the universal in
particular seems to me I mean seems to
be so much about what Christianity has
been in its history yeah and so how do
you then translate that let's say to
because you building churches is
something but you also work on houses
you you you create neighborhoods you try
to bring that same thinking let's say
into it into your buildings no sorry
right that's right well I use a I use a
technique when I design a grouping of
houses or a whole neighborhood where I
try to make it I try to design it as
though it's evolving over time because
when we look at a medieval town in
Europe you know in which we see is just
immensely beautiful nobody designed that
town it just evolved that way who that
way I'm almost like almost like a like
in like a symbiotic relationship of
different things with different agendas
and you know one bit somebody would put
a house there and then the next I would
come along and he'd build his house next
to it the next guy and the space left
over was the street and Speke wasn't
straight it was curving because nobody
had really surveyed it out and you know
the stores were built where it seemed to
make sense to somebody to build the
store and then that building would get
torn down and the taller one would be
built there and everybody would be kind
of reacting to everybody else but there
was nobody really in charge of it
in this way this this we can easily see
look looking at European towns creates
the greatest beauty you know it's it's
it's it's like it's sort of like an icon
of civilization an icon of people living
together harmoniously which is much more
beautiful than the sort of fascist
classicist vision of degree the great
city planner who designs everything
people will just live there and they
better be happy with it you know that
you know that produces a certain kind of
order that has a kind of beauty of
itself but it's not exactly the beauty
of love it's not exactly the beauty of
everybody just getting along you see in
a medieval town and planned but there's
also in the medieval town there will be
something for example like the the
Cathedral in the middle or the church in
the center will have a more let's say
deliberate aspect to it yeah then as you
move out into the community then you
have this more organic development of
relationship there's always like this
hierarchy of relationships you know
there is a hierarchy yeah you'll often
see in many medieval cities you'll see
one hilltop has the Cathedral another
hilltop has has the king's palace and so
there's this sort of duality of secular
and sacred rule all over the city but
isn't it isn't it fascinating how they
completely fail to actually rule the
city that there's all this total chaos
of twisty streets and everything mixed
together in between and the forces of
order are trying to push themselves to
the top and say look look order symmetry
and everybody else is just saying yeah
you know we're gonna do what we're gonna
do and that's you know again that's the
beauty of human civilization is the
tension to do yeah well it's it's it's
tension that just resolves itself all by
itself and you know ultimately it's a
city full of people just you know
drinking beer in cafes and getting along
just fine you know that's that's the
beauty of human civilization that we see
in these unplanned medieval city is so I
try to what I design I try to keep that
that that kind of relaxed quality that
even even if I am the one designing
everything I don't make it look that way
mm-hmm in a way I do that is I don't
design everything at once
I designed the first house and I just
imagine well maybe the person who lives
in this house
you know like spoke architecture and
will make that house really ornate and I
get that house all done and that's where
it is and I say well let's suppose the
next person comes along and you know
it's no longer 1650 you know it's 1710
so this person's going to have a more
more Georgian classical kind of house
you know it's gonna be more of a strange
more symmetrical and he's going to put
it right here you know and I'll design
that house and you know then the next
person comes along now it's you know
1840 so you know now we've got another
style and he's gonna put his house here
and you know now it's the Victorian time
so we're gonna have us have a house
that's painted really really really
interesting Victorian colors a big front
porch and that one's gonna go there it's
arbitrary but the point is I don't have
to go back I'd want to say oh because
I've made this house like that it'd be
great if the house at the other end of
the street or also had a porch to be
symmetric or no no no all right just I
just kind of let each thing be its own
thing and imagine that the next person's
reacting to that you know and I can kind
of I can contrive a street of houses
that looks like nobody actually designed
it right but the thing is this is my I
guess this is gonna be my next question
is that if I look at your work you do
that mmm
but you don't come up to the twentieth
century or let's say the later part of
this one edge memory that is you you've
kind of cut that part out and I'm
curious to know why is it that you don't
take as much influence from modern
styles or from a kind of post-world War
two
architecture well part of us was
practical the reality is doing a good
building in a contemporary modernist
style is really hard and really
expensive and not very many clients want
that at least my clients don't usually
want that there's other architects who
specialize in that but more
philosophically speaking I think we can
see that the the architecture of what we
might say sort of refine European
civilization the architecture of the
late Middle Ages through you know the
nineteen forty or so although it's a
progression of many styles and expresses
many many sort of characters and
personality is it's basically all a
common expression of one idea one idea
of what beauty and harmony
and the good life of living and living
in you know in a civic utopia means to
to European culture where as we see a
real disjoint with with modernistic
architecture it no longer expresses the
same anthropology the like I kind of
think of modernism as a as a philosophy
perhaps perhaps I might even call it a
heresy in anthropological heresy
well basically what modernists and
modernist architects believe is that man
of nowadays is a fundamentally different
creature
for man of the old days they they kind
of think that man of 1650 and man of
1850 were really the same man and they
were building similar building this in
their ignorance yeah because they didn't
know any better but man of post 1940 or
so is is an enlightened being as sort of
a sort of god-like person who stands
above all of that history and that
nowadays may I know is that the
buildings are machines for living in
that they're not they're not just works
of craftsmanship like they used to be
there there now a sort of icon of social
science whether there are an expression
of how of how we live our incredibly
engineered if modern lives and modern
martyr to modernist believers and
modernism like that they actually think
that it's simply wrong to build
traditional buildings they think that
well it was fine for somebody a hundred
years ago to build a traditional
building that for somebody now to build
a traditional building his fit is
intrinsically fake because because were
it were a different creature there's
also this idea of progress like the
you can't you can't go back but that
it's simply early into our nature you
know it's like it's like yeah as a early
and as if you know I decided to put a
put like the Japanese pagoda in the
middle of my street among among all my
european-style houses it's like that's
not of our culture that has nothing to
do with us anymore it's not it's not
ours that's what they see with with the
kind of traditional buildings that I
design is that it's somehow failing to
show that modern man is a different
person than historic man well of course
as Christians we can't believe that as
Christians we believe that God created
man in His image and that image is
unchanging and that man today is the
same as man yesterday no matter how many
delusional totalitarian theories of
reshaping the world in our image we may
we may invent we're the same people we
used to be and the same thing as a
beautiful to our eyes that's used to be
so you know for that reason I have a
philosophical problem with modernism
that doesn't mean I don't think that
good modernist buildings are beautiful
um you know I love many modernist
buildings but I find them beautiful in
the same kind of way that I find
clockwork mechanisms and circuit boards
and fine fine machinery and all sorts of
things that are very alien to our
organic human nature many of these
things are extremely beautiful but you
know as beautiful as I find a you know a
polished brass clockwork mechanism I
don't want to leave it that you know
that's it's it's immoral to behold yeah
but it's it's not really it's not really
the natural expression of our of our
human nature to live in or to worship in
and there is something about it's in
this alienation or the modern alienation
which we that everybody is experiencing
everybody kind of suggests this sense of
this alienation from our communities
from you know from the meaning
that had think that it's given meaning
to civilization for so long and it
seemed like you can see it in the way
that first of all how cities are are
planned most of it you know this urban
sprawl these just these companies these
suburban houses built you know had
invented them with now any town center
without without anything bringing them
together but also just this you know
just these houses all next to each other
are all made of the cheapest material
they can there's a lack of understanding
of how you know the place we live in
participates in our life and our
identity and our community and so they
they don't seem to care about about
thinking about these things well yeah
and you're right the the if you ask me
what the architectural problem of the
world is it's not it's not martyrs it's
not seriously modernistic buildings
seriously modernistic buildings are
relatively rare with the thought the
problem is just mundane architecture
that people don't really think of as art
at all you know of just one of the mill
suburban houses which are mostly
traditionally styled in a very
superficial way but they completely fail
to to capture that that character that
ethos of buildings of centuries past and
unfortunately the whole the whole
industry of design and building of
houses and and of the end of the
infrastructure that connects them has
been so detached from tradition through
the through the through the broad
influence of modernism in the later
twentieth century
that it's it's very very difficult to
get back there although I work hard to
make my building this look like they
just grew there and nobody really
designed them in fact the only way I can
get them built and get them to have that
character is if I take take absolute
control over and I'll detail and just
insist that everything be done exactly
as I dictate it's a strange paradox but
you know in the nine
century you could just give a builder a
set of plans that just you know showed
us a rectangular house with four rooms
and six windows on the front and he
built it beautifully and it would look
great you know nowadays anything that
you don't dictate gets built along and
gets built the ugliest possible way so
yeah I have to be I have to be going the
fascist architect in okay in order in
order to achieve the look of nobody
having designed it yeah and also the
irony about your buildings is that
because we live in this world that is so
gray or so you know so plastic that when
someone encounters the building it's
this wondrous surprise it's almost like
opening up a fairy tale book or opening
up some some forgotten mystery that we
that we haven't encountered before and
so although your buildings are in a
certain manner they they tried to be
have this kind of no one designed them
but they also end up being this this
total surprise to people I mean I have
seen people come to the church here in
Charleston for the first time and you
can just see in their eyes that they're
it's like they're children again and
they're walking into this this this
they're walking into a story exactly and
you you get that sense oh that's op
that's also a paradox that something
which is trying to be so part of the the
landscape so integrated and and ends up
having the opposite effect just because
we live in such a banal boring world oh
yeah and it's a shock to people to see
that that such beauty can still be
created nowadays because because so many
people have gotten resigned to the
experience that that everything new is
bland and boring and yeah it's true when
seeing a new building that's as
beautiful as historic building gives
people a special pleasure and a special
appreciation that they actually wouldn't
see in the historic building mm-hmm yeah
you know it's it's it's kind of like the
hope it gives you what it does and it's
also gives you a sense of a sense of
ownership it's like it's like seeing
other people's children do something
that children do
you know it's just you know that's what
children do but seeing your own child
dwarf or a strong wine you know oh it's
amazing that's the best thing I ever saw
you know because it's yours yeah yeah so
it gives people a very very particular
and unexpected joy to get to come into
one of these buildings and and and and
when it's finally sinks in that this is
actually a completely new building yeah
they're quite shocked and very and very
happy about it really yeah and I think
that that's something that what I felt
is the same in our work that we've been
doing together that the design that
we've worked on you know that we we've
had a mix of your designs and my
carvings and we brought things together
I get the same sense I get the sense
that we're looking at an object which
which which is totally traditional thank
you are the things we've done are
totally traditional no one could
complain about that we're trying to
somehow you know innovate or insert our
own ideas or whatever but when you look
at them there's this complete surprise
at the same time and I when I show
people what we're doing I get that Santa
I show people you know people I need on
the street who ask you what I'm doing
and I say you know I make I make
religious art you know I kind of
downplayed really and I say oh and I'm a
religious Carver and I make people are
first of all they don't believe you they
think yeah that doesn't exist anymore in
here in North America that's not
possible and then the other phone or
anything so going you know what you go
by website and they look at carving that
they can't believe it
they have this sense of surprise you
know not because you we've seen
religious art being made today which you
look at it and you just you just want to
pass by but there's something about I
think that it really is this is the same
desire that you expressed at the
beginning this desire to both capture
something Universal but also join it
with something very particular something
that is very grounded and that little
hint of something no one has seen before
like something a little bit hint of that
yeah yeah even the like the carvings
that we're doing now these this mix of
stones and everything you know no one
has ever done that before it's actually
totally new
don't have historical examples of it but
when you look at them you think you feel
totally at home you feel like yeah this
is something that should have been made
a thousand years ago maybe it wasn't but
here it is being made today so so yes I
I always feel like we're the luckiest
people worldwide we're doing what we're
doing like whoo hoo hoo I know I
wouldn't have thought that it was
possible so it's great that we're able
to do it so what is your I mean I think
that that's maybe something to talk
about because one of the things that I
feel it's happening is that there is a
there is a renewal of interest in some
of these this vision we've seen it in
something in the hipster movements you
know in the in the steampunk aesthetics
that we've seen this desire to recapture
the old world in a manner which is both
connected to it but also there's a
freshness to it at the same time so
maybe you can talk a little bit on how
you see that cuz here at Charleston
there is the the school of house in the
school of the American College of the
building arts right yeah yeah I that's
this new College in Charleston that I
serve on the advisory board it's it's
the American College of the building
arts and it's a liberal arts four-year
undergraduate college and advanced
degree is in timber framing
architectural carpentry blacksmithing
plastering masonry brick laying stone
carving they've now just added a major
in in in classical drafting classical
architecture drafting decorative
finishes is coming next so students can
actually go there to get a bachelor's
degree as in college and come out with
this practical skill set that gets them
that's them immediately get a job and
work in a very high level in these
fields and this is this College has I
think I think about the highest draw
placement rate of any college America I
mean everybody who comes out of this
College immediately gets a well-paying
job in there
noise because the you know so much need
for people who can do these things not
only for restoring old buildings but but
for building new building right in
there's a there's a there's a shortage
of craftsmen who can do it but there's a
big revival of interest in it this is
this this you know there's quite a lot
of architects who design good
traditional buildings and need people
can build these things and yeah I'm
quite hardened actually you know the I
think things are getting better not
worse regards to the quality of design
and craftsmanship you know you may have
to know where to look you know you may
have it may only be a tiny tiny
minuscule percentage of all the work
being done it's actually good beautiful
work but if you if you look in the right
place if you look for it
the work being done nowadays is as good
as any work that's ever been being done
I mean there's more and more people
every year who know how to do it of
course we see this in in our field of
Orthodox liturgical arts I mean the the
the iconography and the architecture
being done in the washing Church right
now in in many ways is better than it
ever has been better than it wasn't
centuries ago which is a which is
astonishing to see that it can flourish
in this day and age she had an extent
and the same the same is true of many
kinds of craftsmanship and it's fed by
as you said this larger interest in this
among the sort of hipster generation in
in in the retro aesthetic you know it
often takes a superficial form you know
we can see it in graphic design and in
the sort of posters for events that look
like they're out of the Old West or out
of out of the warring twenty years and
you know here in Charleston every new
bar and restaurant is like look looks
like it's from the 1920s it's all marble
and polished brass and you know Bart
bartenders wearing vests and bowties and
you know playing swing dance music and
so forth you know it's really it's
really charming to see because you know
that's a that's a beautiful aesthetic
and it actually means something you know
you can you know I can see the appeal of
it because you don't have to you know
to invent yourself you know if you're
drawn to that aesthetic you know you can
put on the outfit and you can step into
that bar and you can order that cocktail
and all of a sudden there's a whole a
whole galaxy of aesthetic references and
romantic romantic associations that you
that you put onto yourself that you can
enjoy that evening and you know that is
so much more fun than the modern vision
of a building is just a white box and
you know you have to you have to invent
everything from scratch
yeah who has the time for that who has
to it who has the time to invent their
entire self-image and aesthetic taste X
neat you know yeah so maybe I'm thinking
maybe the the last question I'd like to
ask you to tell me a little bit about
the beer store so one of the things that
you did in Charleston's that you
designed the beer store and it's an
absolute it's marvelous I mean it's it's
it's this it's a on one end it's a crazy
space you know you walk in there and it
it feels completely surreal but it's
also I have that same feeling of also
feeling like it's been there forever or
that it just belongs there so maybe you
can tell us a little bit about how you
thought of this how you how you were
able to think of even proposing a beer
store that would look like that well
it's it's funny there's a developer here
in Charleston who had built a very fine
restaurant Edmund toast and he he gave a
kind of an 18th century historical
reference in its in its name and it's
its style of design and then there was a
he decided they wanted to open a craft
beer and wine store attached to the
restaurant and they wanted it to be kind
of a showpiece of architecture because
he he owns a lot of property in the
and wants to kinda bring up the
standards of development in in this kind
of formally industrial area that doesn't
have a lot of good build in this so
anyway he asked me to design that the
beer and wine store and pretty much gave
me carte blanche to do anything I wanted
which is which is very unusual
so I guess I give him a lot of credit
for having having that vision that just
a beer store could be the building that
brings up the whole neighborhood ranks
at an actual center of commercial life
for blocks around but though that was
his idea so I I basically put into
practice all of the ideas I've developed
for for designing Orthodox churches
because a lot of them just happened to
apply really well here the idea that you
don't have any windows on the walls the
light comes down from above through a
cupola worked really well because we
needed the walls to be lined with with
shelving instead of having windows on
them and I did the whole interior in
timber frame Marcos because I'm not I'm
not sure how to explain it but everybody
seems to intuitively know yeah and and
just you know the appearance of all the
bottles of beer and wine on the shelves
is so beautiful because they all have
different kind of labels and different
shaped bottles and you know so I
realized you know I don't need any color
in this building because the beer and
wine bar will start all over color and
texture so I did everything on the
inside in just boiled pine and I wanted
the details to look really really
handmade so the closer you get up to the
shelves and to the Timbers them you can
just see everybody's craftsmanship is I
I designed these these turned columns to
hold up all of the shelves over 300 of
them that this is this local lady who's
a woodturner me
and then the outside I did the I did the
building and solid masonry and I used
salvaged antique brick to build the
artisans because I wanted to have that
working on that quality that old brick
has that's really hard to find a new
brick and I had to teach the Masons how
to how to do that because they never
actually built the extraction torches
out of it he does that anymore yeah it
was it was a very fun project and I kind
of I coordinated all the craftsmen many
of whom were from the College of the
building actually they built the timber
framing and all the interior carpentry
for me you know cuz it feels when you go
in there it feels like you're walking
into like a now chemical store or
something something that's nothing
magical yes it does it does seem that
way because it really shows off like the
the bottles almost does artwork yes
exactly that way but but but not like a
modern one painted or gallery but but in
more like artwork and a like like going
into like the that the the the chamber
of exotic treasures in like a baroque
aristocrats palace yeah exactly
kinda that the quality I wanted you know
everything seems fun and mysterious yeah
yeah that's it's it's funny because the
space has such such formality with the
you know with the the coop and the the
extreme symmetry of the timber frame in
there and everything being handmade
people react really quite quite
peculiarly when they go in there they
for one thing they go in there and they
get they have hushed voices like when
they go here to it sure yeah yeah they
kind of realize that there's something
there's something almost sacred about
there and they don't want to talk loudly
they just look and then they and then
they won't leave yeah you know
especially when the store first opened
and people are in there for the first
time there was this funny phenomenon
where where people would go in and
they'd buy the beer and they'd be
standing there and they they'd have the
basket they'd have bought it and they'd
just be standing there and then summer
sales person would come after
and say you do need me thing can I help
you and they said oh oh I guess I was
leaving just kept happening and
happening in the store was full of
people just standing there looking at
they're looking at it and you know not
knowing what they're supposed to do next
you know it's kind of you know it's kind
of like at a church service where nobody
will leave until the priest gives the
dismiss yes it's time to me it's like
they want to be told what it's time to
go okay it's funny it's a funny
phenomenon that's amazing that's totally
amazing well it shows you the power of
what architecture can do that's for sure
that's right
all right and dude thank you so much
thank you so much this isn't a lot of
fun I hope we'll have to figure out
another another discussion one of the
things you wanted to talk about which I
said we shouldn't isn't a relationship
between orthodoxy Pires and so maybe our
next discussion can be something I mean
Andrew even actually brought his pirate
hat well because I was hoping we were
funny to discuss that so yeah so our
next conversation is going to be about
the relationship between orthodoxy
piracy oh yeah I promise you guys so
thanks thank you it's great to have you
all right Thank You Jonathan beri